[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
atx de la réhabilitation pour l'équipe
de france de football qui note blanche
contre l'équipe d'espagne à colombes
devant 50000 spectateurs en 90 minutes
cette équipe a retrouvé élan et
dynamisme il ne lui manque qu'une chose
un peu de personnes depuis que ma
françois petit numéro 10 après s'y être
reprise à 3 fois illustre assez bien là
peu près qui marque la fin de la plupart
des deux principes face à
l'espanyol trento numéro 11 qui a
tendance à confondre course à pied
football créée ici une fois n'est pas
coutume une situation dangereuse pour
l'équipe de france
de fait les vedettes du real madrid 10
et stephano en tête numéro 9 n'ont
convaincu personne et le but
d'égalisation que marc l'espagne est
entaché d'un hors-jeu flagrant que n'a
pas vu la vitre il est vrai qu arbitre
n'a pas vu grand chose au cours de ce
match
les avants français ont tout de même
donné une fois le grand frisson aux
spectateurs des tribunes sur cette
attaque
cinquante mille spectateurs debout crois
qu'elle va faire mouche
eh bien non match nul pour les deux
équipes
à son retour à elisabethville know is
sound et président de la république
katangaise a pu entendre crépiter les
mitrailleuses dans la capitale en effet
c'est la guerre une guerre de rue qui
opposent les troupes katangaise aux
casques bleus de l'onu passé à
l'offensive
guerre sainte jusqu'à l'éviction des
troupes de l'onu a proclamé le
gouvernement qu'attendait guerre totale
contre le katanga a affirmé le
secrétaire de l'onu
et à elisabethville chaque jour il ya
des morts et des blessés
à bruxelles ces événements ont provoqué
une manifestation de réprobation contre
les nations unies arborant des slogans
dénués d'aménité les manifestants ont
conspué l'organisation internationale
à paris les ministres des affaires
étrangères de grande-bretagne et des
etats-unis d'allemagne de france se sont
trouvés au quai d'orsay entretien 4 qui
avait ouvert une grande semaine
diplomatique celle ci devait en effet
voir se réunir également dans la
capitale française les 6 du marché
commun et les 15 de l'otan
[Musique]
devant le buste que neuilly sur seine a
dédié à jean mermoz un groupe est venu
saluer cette grande figure de l'aviation
qui disparu il ya exactement 25 ans au
dessus de l'atlantique
liquidera cavaillès était là vieux
compagnons de la grande aventure j'en
ernaux était l'homme qui pour la
première fois avait traversé
l'atlantique sud son exploit paris-dakar
natale buenos aires et retour à bord de
l'arc en ciel avait déchaîné
l'enthousiasmé et paris lui avait fait
après sa double traversée une sorte de
trion c'est que l'exploit avec une
signification plus haute qu'un beau
geste sportif il ouvrait à l'aviation un
domaine jusqu'ici inviolée et inauguré
la ligne commerciale qui de toulouse par
casa dakar natale et buenos aires
monnaie jusqu'à santiago du chili
le 7 décembre 1936 à bord de la croix du
sud jean mermoz partait pour sa 24e
traversée au large de dakar ont perdu sa
trace le ca n'a jamais rien rendu mais
jean mermoz était entré à la fois dans
l'histoire et dans la légende
[Applaudissements]
l'océan pacifique le relief africain et
pour finir la terre toute entière c'est
ce qu'avait au coût de ces deux
rotations autour de notre planète et nos
100 ch à penser ou plutôt la caméra
automatique qui l'accompagnait le
mouvement de rotation du globe est ici
50 fois plus rapide que dans la réalité
[Musique]
un document qui sera sans doute vite
dépassé les un document qui fixe une
étape un document qu en somme dans cent
ans on regardera avec une certaine
condescendance peut-être mais non sans
doute sans attendrissement
[Musique]
jean delannoy a joué les père noël avant
la lettre en remettant à renée marie
potet au nom des auteurs de films le
prix suzanne bianchetti qui récompense
les brillants débuts d'une jeune
comédienne est raide pradier et chic à
jour où et quelques autres lauréates des
années passées étaient venus saluer
cette nouvelle venue dans le champ des
étoiles
[Musique]
le temps n'est plus où la coiffure
s'improvisait dans un salon de quartier
elle possède aujourd'hui c'est utile ces
laboratoires tels à aulnay sous bois
près de paris les plus grands
laboratoires capillaire d'europe
c'est là que journaliste et spécialiste
de la beauté féminine sont venus
assister à la première de modeling
nouvelles techniques de la coiffure
qu'alexandre et jacques dessange met
aujourd'hui en pratique
en ligne ont sans doute que l'histoire
de la coiffure moderne ne date que de
1882 avec l'apparition de l'ondulation
l'un des frises à bhl ne date que du
début de ce siècle et l'on en était
encore aujourd'hui à hésiter entre la
permanente durable et la mise en plis
sans permanente mais éphémère désormais
les coiffures souple et naturel dureront
plus longtemps et chaque femme se
rassurent coiffée avec la plus grande
facilité
[Musique]
ma jing une nouveauté qui prend dans le
domaine de la mode une allure de
révolution
[Applaudissements]
la membrolle en indre et loire est
aujourd'hui un nom d'espoir à l'orée
d'un bois de chêne a été créé le premier
centre destiné non seulement à la
désintoxication mais aussi à la
réadaptation des malades alcooliques
l'originalité de la cure de la membrolle
est un effet d'associer le traitement
psychologique coloré de contacts humains
au traitement physiologique classique à
base de pilules des spirales provoquant
le dégoût de l'alcool
à cet effet le centre ne se présente pas
comme un simple établissement
hospitalier il met à profit avec une
salle de spectacle et une bibliothèque
un vaste atelier en un mot un cadre
adapté à de multiples activités
professionnelles ou récréatives dont le
but est d'assurer la réadaptation à la
vie collective voire la promotion
sociale guéri et réadapter le malade
sera par la suite suivi pour la cure
d'entretien par un dispensaire d'ores et
déjà 150 cas traités sont là pour
témoigner en faveur de cette méthode
nouvelle 150 alcoolique délivrés de leur
esclavage
[Musique]
et
m
se souvient temps de landru dont les
exploits en pire la place voici 40 ans
c'est en 1919 que le petit journal dans
un discret tantôt filet annonce à
l'arrestation d'un certain andru pour
d'obscurs histoire de disparition on
l'avait arrêté un matin dans
l'appartement de montmartre où il
habitait sous le nom de guillet il
devait aussi plus tard outre différents
noms portés celui de barbe bleue et la
presse publié à cette mauvaise photo qui
devaient rendre une barbe sellette car
la sphère de jour en jour prenait une
extension imprévus ont compté jusqu'à 11
personnes que la fréquentation de landru
semblait avoir mystérieusement retirés
de la circulation
de là à penser au crime il n'y avait
qu'un pas il fut franchi allègrement
procéder d'une simplicité enfantine les
petites annonces matrimoniales drainer
vers landru le trouble sentimentale d
existence solitaire la faire se nouait à
la gare et souci d'économie que
comprendront les bons administrateurs
landru prenait alors un aller retour et
un aller simple on allait à la campagne
à gand des ou landru possédait une ville
départ et mue vers une citerne banlieue
arbres ou dans une atmosphère de show de
tendresse ou de brûlantes passion on
ferait des rêves d'avenir
la villa de gambais s'avérait bourgeoise
et isolé pour accoupler l'amour et la
solitude et douce bien chauffés au
surplus et ses cheminées et cette
solitude devait faire bientôt marcher
les lentes par la police 20 bien entendu
recherché à granby les disparus ces onze
victimes landru les aurait-il intérêt
après les avoir trucidé et terrassiers
des thérère devant un andru impassible
quelques ossements trop peu au gré des
enquêteurs et un soupçon pris corps
landru brûle et il dans sa petite
cuisinière du modèle courant les restes
sanglants de ces épouses successives
les jeter t-il au brochet le vrai et
qu'on ne trouva rien ou presque
[Applaudissements]
le 7 novembre 21 le procès s'ouvrait à
versailles pour l'édification d'un
public insatiable les journaux
n'hésitèrent devant aucun détail tout le
monde connu la topographie de la salle
d'audience les attitudes de l'accusé les
mouvements de l'accusation les pièces à
conviction ou la cuisinière et le carnet
de dépenses tenait la place d'honneur
onu la pâmoison en plein prétoire de
celle qui n'avait pu faire le voyage de
granby ont dû les pièces noires de moro
giafferi son cri des hypothèses oui des
preuves non et le 30 novembre 21 le
verdict est la condamnation landru
n'avait pas avoué il n'avouera jamais et
monsieur deibler mis le point final à
cette page de la petite histoire
[Musique]